you got my training box yeah yeah no but
you've always said if the deal is good
enough you'll find the person well but
as soon as the off on that let's accept
it guarantee you with it hours yeah
you've been phoning us breathing down
our neck saying I need you put some
funds on your dry day and then it's like
you know I mean so we need to find an
investor for that now how do we do that
how we gonna do that
you got a job you got to buy a house you
pay off your mortgage you've been fired
this is the stuff that doesn't really
get talked about like wow just may not
run a property that I can't afford in
the training and in the industry I'm not
just saying Samuel I'm saying generally
this I feel like this stuff doesn't get
talked about like I'm intimidated by a
piece of paper which is absolutely
ridiculous is what I'm doing illegal yes
well that makes things a little bit more
awkward doesn't it Sammy was obviously
annoyed that I'm having these like
mental blocks right now why you stressed
but because this this whole thing from
all of this has been my what I've been
scared of like the deals that
communicating to people dealing with
estate agents looking around property
I'm alright with I'm confident with that
sorry I'm sorry
you're the deal yeah if it stacks up I
don't quite understand what you're
scared why are you worried about this
intimidates me why this this is a piece
of paper I know it I know it is but it's
there
this is gonna cost more than I thought I
would well originally but I always had
it in my head it would be 750 pounds to
do all the contracts yeah they are after
speaking with it's a little bit more
plus back it's it's about to do I know I
know I know but this is is thing dude I
can't I can't deal with this